[Music]
we recently told you about research
showing instagram can have a negative
impact on mental health and body image
especially for teen girls now a growing
community of writers and poets are
trying to turn the platform into a force
for positive change jamie yukas
introduces us to two authors who are
helping their millions of followers see
light during dark times
diamonds form
under pressure
[Music]
we normally come together with many
unresolved issues because healing simply
takes time
whenever you feel crushed under pressure
or in darkness
you're in a powerful place of
transformation and transmutation
diego perez who uses the pen name young
pueblo and leila delia live on opposite
coasts but are connected through a
community of authors turning the page on
what it means to be a writer we must
continually outgrow who we have been in
order to continually develop into who we
were created to become
they both use social media to spread
positive messages of hope and
self-discovery gaining power through
pain and musings of what it means to
love yourself
the way i write is from the heart and
from the soul and so the fact that
people are gravitating to that message
that inner calling a lot of people are
looking for another way of being in the
world misery is going out of style
people are tired of being miserable you
know you can have money you can like
have beautiful things in your life but
if your mind is constantly reacting it's
very easy for you to ruin things for
yourself young pueblo's posts are simple
next time you feel agitated
because you're falling back into past
patterns his words powerful and
insightful remember that simply being
aware
that you are repeating the past
is a sign of progress and are resonating
with the millions of people following
him on social media so we're in prospect
park which is where you started riding i
would spend so many precious quiet
moments here just trying to
one figure out my life and just figure
out what i was actually understanding
about myself he likes to call himself an
explorer not a teacher his latest new
york times bestselling book lays out how
to find clarity and connection something
he struggled with for much of his life i
never wanted to admit to myself that i
actually felt pretty sad and depressed
inside what was the rock bottom moment
for you
just partying way too much doing too
many different drugs and just pushing
myself
way too far i felt like my life was like
slipping
from reality so i took the drugs i
flushed them down the toilet and from
that day forward that's when all the
honesty started he says vipassana
meditation which means to see things as
they really are
changed his life it's now the biggest
part of his identity and backbone of his
work meditation made me realize that i
don't need to cause myself this extra
mental pain the moment you allow what
happened to strengthen you
you win
vulnerability and pain are also at the
center of delia's work i was
at the threshold of taking my own life i
was in depression coming from back to
back domestic violence partnerships it
was a lot and i didn't know how to
express that pain and i didn't know how
to stop down spiraling and so breaking
that cycle for me was the turning point
so many of us come to our higher selves
through pain through that portal dalia
has amassed more than a half million
followers doing what she loves as a
spiritual writer
what's it like for you to be back at the
beach a place you like to write
feels like home
she encourages people to vibrate higher
daily aptly the title of her new book
it just means that day after day that
you have this
commitment and your actions are an
affirmation they're a meditation they're
offerings to this commitment to
live at a higher level just remember who
you are and remember your practice it
seems like for a lot of people part of
the practice now is going to instagram
to writers spaces like yours and looking
at it and feeling inspired for the day
absolutely like getting messages from
people saying that i was going to give
up
you know your words help me this right
here it lets me know that i'm doing my
part to help the world vibrate higher in
some way there are now hundreds if not
thousands of accounts on instagram that
boast positive messages and while many
of these writers have secured book deals
through their success
the underlying goal and hope is simply
to help other people find their
happiness from within you talk a lot
about happiness doesn't come from a
relationship
a job
your family it comes from yourself yeah
can you help people understand that idea
a lot of happiness you know it has to be
cultivated from within you loving
yourself you being aligned with your
values and you also having a deep
appreciation of impermanence i think a
lot of the times the mental struggles
that we have are because we just reject
the fact that things are constantly
changing life is this
constant movement of change that we
don't really have control over do you
think that's why your writings are
speaking to so many people right now
absolutely i mean the world is a massive
transition everything's changing there
have always been problems historically
that people had to deal with but now we
have
a greater amount of accessibility in
regards to
accessing tools that can deeply heal
ourselves and that's what's always been
missing for cbs mornings jamie yukis in
los angeles
didn't you guys like the line misery is
going out of style yeah i like that a
lot and delia vibrate higher daily just
watching delia and jamie on the beach
together like that was pretty calming
yeah yeah and they're right change is
happening so quickly i think that's why
people are flocking to those messages of
support yeah vibrating highly higher be
around people that give you the great
vibrations exactly people that don't get
rid of them yeah all toxis all toxicity
out i so agree with that
all right good good good vibrations
speech voice that could be a song
and you can hear more of jamie's
conversation with diego and layla on the
cbs morning's podcast for now we'll be
right back
[Music]